selon une étude 50% des femmes et 60 %
des hommes pensent à une autre personne
que leur partenaire pendant qu'ils font
l'amour
alors franchement benjamin castaldi est
ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé
vous pensez à vos ex aux femmes ça a dû
marie-mai plus quand j'étais plus jeune
c'est à dire il ya deux semaines selon
les diarrhées mais samuel est sûr que
non non jamais ma femme regarde
l'émission donc en version kelly ça vous
est déjà arrivé
non mais ça m'est déjà arrivé de penser
à ce que j'avais dîné le soir mais pas
une autre personne est d'accord abel
parce qu'à vous faire un carnage
c'est un aspirateur de tablettes elles
sont la mère tu laisserais d'une
pistache en 2000 elle même et à raison
qui flânent benhaim oui
j'ai repensé à quelqu'un d'autre que
patton notre figurez-vous non parce que
je suis toujours à ce que je fais je
suis très appliqué oui ban a foncé c'est
bien si concentré à l'essai mais c'est
beau elle est très très bon merci en
tout cas vous fait une très belle entrée
alors jean missionnaire est ce que vous
avez déjà pensé vous à la personne
gouverneur philibert et vous que rare
bon c'est vrai que je pense rarement à
ma meuf quand je lui fais l'amour
jean lucas du côté de ça il ya quelques
années quand un artiste peut on a
toujours le cerveau en ébullition les
trains n'a besoin d'un imaginaire très
fécond pour après fermé spectacle et
moyens coup c'est vrai que je pense à
thann autre chose jean luc tu as connu
ça ou pas je sais pas mais la chaîne
aujourd'hui
non mais attends ton quartier
je suis un mec très beau cul ce qu'on
suppose - amoureux de bd l'année où
jamais pour ça qu'on a quelqu'un de
l'équipe allait parfois en comparaison
avec les anciennes copines c'est bien
c'est très mauvais un de comparer une
personne à l'autre comparaison n'est pas
raison commande là mais bon je voudrais
quelqu'un de l'équipe allait on réduit
la sur ce côté là ça fait trop chaud
t'es pas tout non mais ça m'est déjà
arrivé de faire une immense confusion au
ces il a nous sommes dans les années 90
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'appelle la police tout cas à la faute
oui alors oui à l'époque je suis très à
l'aise sur minitel pour laisser la
chatroulette
ah oui alors oui 10 15 aline on peut le
site et ça n'existe plus à l'époque je
faisais beaucoup de rencontres j'ai
rencontré l'amour et avant de rencontrer
l'amour je me suis dispersé et j'ai
rencontré plusieurs personnes ont montré
la voie vous avez surtout votre peuvent
perdu votre portefeuille et un moment
voilà une belle rencontre au moment
fatidique au moment de conclure je crie
mais vers os et j'avais du plaisir allez
le cadre y est c'était ça ramène quand
tu fais l'amour tu en gagnes la gonzesse
[Musique]
la porte du frigo vous alors moi je
pense à l'épicier parce que dans ma tête
sur ma liste de courroie quoi patienter
jusque dans ma tête c'est une manie de
ben ali doit être coton des rôdeurs
garder un semblant une fois que le plan
orsec est un clan c'est en vain il ya
des radis noir est-ce qu'il a gravi noir
rit pas hélas elles m'ont nul à dieu
nous a une option pour l'instant et je
suis prêt at-il dans ton au magic la
vérité mais je suis prêt à tout entendre
ce qui se passe je me les pose une
question parce qu'il ya un sondage qui
est sorti et 50% des hommes des femmes
et 60 % des hommes pensent à une autre
personne que leur partenaire pendant
qu'ils font l'amour
matthieu delormeau est ce que ça vous
est déjà arrivé avec quelqu'un de
l'équipe dédiée ou koné ou qu'on connaît
alors qu'on connaît oui alors ça
m'arrivait s'étaient dévoués et à un
plan à trois ce qui était bon mais
j'aimais parce qu'il fait des trucs et
ils accéléraient alors c'est cocasse gym
j'imaginais qu'on est étroit et avec
brad pitt je ne sais pas pourquoi à
l'hôtel plaza et il a rien à [ __ ] ils
étaient quand il était avec nous aussi
donc voter à l'hôtel plaza
oui c'est pas mon corps qui vous dérange
[Rires]
samedi 11 de ses chers fait quoi le sait
pas que c'est pas moi qui ai payé assez
pas non plus sur ce qui était fou c'est
qu'à un moment donné c'était tellement
chaud et sensuel entre nous qui se
retire du plan à trois et ils nous
regardent
non a dit oui pour des leçons il a voulu
et celui ça c'est une belle légende
d'auteur et dont vous faisiez comme
beaucoup de personnes je vous entends
des gémir mathieu et c'est toujours
quelque chose qui me qu'il me fallait
que non mais ça m'angoisse voir il c'est
ici qu'on ait plu au public
merci du témoignage agathe agathe au
projet
bonjour ça va ça va toi
un dauphin
tutoie le soleil
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la sanction
je suis désolé chef oui alors non mais
non bien sûr que non ça ne m'est jamais
arrivé vous m'en fous bien sûr comme en
plus quand je suis avec quelqu'un il n'a
plus aucune concurrence je vois plus
rien autour mais il de il cristallise
défense n'ont pas bayard est cristalline
c'est à dire qu'il boit toujours que
staline et boit que de l'eau le cas
c'est un mec à sa faute chacun mais
qu'il boit que de l'eau j'en ai ras le
bol vous avez été honnête j'aimerais un
peu plus d'honnêteté break lors de
cholet mais je vais être très honnête
quelqu'un équipes n'ont personne même
isabelle surtout pas elle était dans la
chambre mais regardez plus que brad a
bah oui j'adore jean-luc mais alors est
donc non ça ça m'est arrivé je vais très
très honnête de ne pas penser à une
personne en particulier mais un match de
foot non psg nantes à la finale 83
doivent de la coupe de france de
football
deuxième victoire du psg à venir en
ligne mais non c'est simplement parce
que il ya des moments les garçons sont
un peu excité et pour venir un peu moins
vite
merci voilà allez merci jean luc vous
voulez la franchise à cause de tirs au
but mois vous n'y a pas de justice car
voilà n'a pas donné pas ça avez vous
n'êtes pas d'ici quel gâchis
je suis heureux quand même à sa merci